oil supply and demand a can be tightened
substantially the next years to come and
it may take conventional oil suppliers
may pick around 20 20 if we do not
discover a new oil fields and if the
demand oil demand grows as strong as it
has been in the past and if we don't do
anything if we just sit back and Russia
station it means if we don't slow down
the oil demand growth if you don't
invest to find new all your fields we
may see much higher prices than we have
seen in the past and this could have a
very bad implications for the global
economy for all the countries in the
world major consumer countries such as
the US China or European countries but
as well as for the producing countries
because oil is one of the major revenue
generators so what we have to do is on
one hand we have to invest to find new
oil fields second perhaps much more
importantly is to slow down the oil
demand quote and we can slow the oil
demand growth finding solution to our
transportation sector problems we have
to find cars we have to use cars much
more efficiently we have to look at the
alternative technologies of cars such as
the biofuels or even more importantly
electric cars a oil sources are there it
is use it is till 2020 and so on but one
day if not 20 30 2013 2014 one day we
will run out of oil the Scimitar of time
so what we have to do is we have to
prepare ourselves for that day and if we
have to leave oil before oil leaves us
I think a first of all our first task is
to postpone the day of a peak and to do
that we have to a invest in oil fits and
we have plenty of oil mainly in the OPEC
countries in a Middle East the spirit of
older we have to see that investment is
done in order to explore new oil fields
and develop the existing fields second a
industry and business need to look at
the alternative option in the
transportation sector today more than
ninety five percent of the growth in oil
demand comes from the transportation
sector namely cars trucks and jets so we
have to find a way industry has to find
a way to get a with the government's to
find new mods new modalities for
transportation this our first task to
postpone the peak and then if we are
very prepared for the day that the
global oil production goes down we can
find solutions to the significant
economic challenges we may face